THE MAN SAYS HE MEANT TO LEAVE
THE HANDGUN IN HIS CAR BEFORE
JOINING THE MOTORCADE BUT FORGOT
TO DO THAT.
THE PRESIDENT IS ON HIS WAY BACK
TO WASHINGTON AFTER SPENDING THE
HOLIDAY WEEKEND AT HIS FLORIDA
RESORT ABOUT AN HOUR FROM THE
PARKLAND SHOOTING SCENE.
HE'S BEEN BUSY ON TWITTER,
POSTING ABOUT MANY TOPICS FROM
OPRAH WINFREY TO THE RUSSIAN
INDICTMENTS.
THE KREMLIN IS WEIGHING IN NOW
ON THE CHARGES AS WELL,
DISMISSING THEM AS PROVING
NOTHING ABOUT RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT
INVOLVEMENT.
CORRESPONDENT KEVIN CORKE IS
OUTSIDE THE PRESIDENT'S FLORIDA
COMPOUND.
GOOD EVENING, KEVIN.
>> GOOD EVENING, MY FRIEND.
WHAT A DIFFERENCE A DAY MAKES.
ONE TWEET ABOUT RUSSIA TODAY
FROM THE PRESIDENT, ONE OF TWO
TWEETS ALL TOLD AND THAT'S A
DRAMATIC DEPARTURE FROM WHAT WE
SAW THE WEEKEND WHEN HE WAS
VIRTUALLY TWEETING NONSTOP ABOUT
THE RUSSIAN INVESTIGATION.
IT WAS A DIGITAL DAY LOSE,
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S TWEET STORM
RAN THE GAMUT OF TOPICS.
THE RUSSIAN INVESTIGATION WAS
FRONT AND CENTER.
IT WAS THE GOAL OF RUSSIA TO
CREATE DISCORD, DISRUPTION,
CHAOS WITHIN THE U.S., THEY HAVE
SIX SUCCEEDED BEYOND THEIR
WILDEST DREAMS.
THE PRESIDENT'S FORAY INTO
TWITTER WAS THE HIS LATEST
ATTEMPT TO DRAW CONTRAST 'TWEEN
HIS REFRAIN OF NO RUSSIA
COLLUSION WITH THE ONGOING
RUSSIA PROBE WHICH DESPITE THE
RECENT INDICTMENTS OF MORE THAN
A DOZEN RUSSIAN NATIONALS IN THE
ONGOING.
PREDICTABLY TODAY THE KREMLIN
REJECT THE NOTION THAT THEY WERE
INTERFERING WITH AMERICANS
ELECTIONS.
>> Translator: LOOKS LIKE
ACCUSATIONS HAVE BEEN MADE BUT
NO EVIDENCE PRESENTED.
AMERICAN SAINT RUSSIA DID NOT
ACKNOWLEDGE OBVIOUS FACTS.
FOR US, THESE AREN'T OBVIOUS AND
AREN'T FACTS.
>> A MEMBER OF THE PRESIDENT'S
CABINET WASN'T SPARED FROM THE
WAVE OF CRITICISM.
THIS COMMENT FROM THE NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISOR AT A SECURITY
SUMMIT IN GERMANY.
>> WITH THE FBI INDICTMENTS, THE
EVIDENCE IS NOW INCONTROVERTIBLE
AND AVAILABLE IN THE PUBLIC
DOMAIN.
>> THE PRESIDENT CHIDED
McMASTER WRITING:
"FORGOT TO SAY THAT THE RESULTS
OF THE 2016 ELECTION WERE NOT
IMPACTED OR CHANGED BY THE
RUSSIANS."
THE FACT THAT THE INDICTMENT
SUGGESTS THE RUSSIANS HAVE BEEN
TARGETING THE U.S.
"OBAMA WAS PRESIDENT UP TO,
AND BEYOND, THE 2016 ELECTION.
SO WHY DIDN'T HE DO SOMETHING
ABOUT RUSSIAN MEDDLING?"
EXACTLY WHAT THEY KNEW ABOUT
RUSSIAN MEDDLING BEFORE THE 2016
ELECTION CALLS INTO QUESTION WHO
COULD HAVE OR SHOULD HAVE DONE
SOMETHING TO STOP IT.
>> OBAMA WAS IN A VERY DIFFICULT
POSITION.
HE DIDN'T WANT TO MAKE IT APPEAR
HE WAS FAVORING HILLARY CLINTON.
MAYBE HE SHOULD HAVE DONE MORE.
>> MR. TRUMP ASSERTS THE
INDICTMENTS MEAN HE IS IN THE
CLEAR, SOME WARN THAT MAY NOT BE
THE CASE.
>> CONGRESSMEN, YOU'VE SEEN THE
INTELLIGENCE.
DO YOU THINK THIS INDICTMENT
SUGGESTS IT'S A CASE CLOSED, NO
COLLUSION?
>> OF COURSE NOT.
THIS IS THE PRESIDENT TO CLAIM
HIS VINDICATION SOMEONE SNEEZES.
>> SPEAKING OF THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION, FORMER
VICE PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN SAID
THEY WERE WALKING THE CONSTANT
TIGHT ROPE ABOUT HOW MUCH OR HOW
LITTLE TO SAY WITH WHAT THEY
KNEW ABOUT RUSSIAN MEDDLING.
THERE ARE BEEN A NUMBER OF
CRITICS IN THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION HAVE ARGUED THEY
SAID DECIDEDLY TOO LITTLE TOO